we are six days away from some lower
elementary school students the k
through third grade returning to
classrooms final preparations do
continue to keep
clark county school district staff and
students safe from possibly spreading
covid 19.
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how one campus is adapting
and the special guest who came by today
a new look at goolsby elementary school
this is very different obviously
caution tape on playgrounds less desks
in classrooms and
social distancing markers on the ground
part of final preparations before
some students return monday for hybrid
learning a mix of in-person class
two days and online the other part of
the week this is the first step to get
our kids back
in front of our teachers superintendent
dr jesus draw tours the campus tuesday
with the school principal
they talk with teachers and see how the
school plans to prevent the spread of
kovid 19.
hand sanitizer we got a big case of that
while all schools follow a district
guideline
certain specifics may be different in
each building we are not
shying away and giving school leaders
the autonomy to do different things
our lunches will be in the lunchroom
we'll in our pre-k in kindergarten will
be in the atrium so they'll get fresh
air
principal danny eichelberger says most
families want to come back
in second grade we have 80 percent of
students returning as well as a majority
of educators
i am thrilled jennifer schankberger gets
ready to adjust
her teaching style not only helping
students in the classroom
but also online we have a cart that has
a chromebook on it that's to follow us
around so if i want to take my little
live streaming kiddos
and bring them around the classroom i
can dr jar says there's no timeline for
bringing back fourth and fifth along
with secondary
school students to campuses yet but
there's a plan in the works following
governor steve syslock announcing
last week new guidelines for reopening
schools
reporting in the west valley kristin
drummond 8 news now
kristin thank you dr jara says that plan
for other grade levels returning will be
shared with the board soon that fourth
grade up right through high school ccsd
has a website
dedicated with information to reopening
schools for hybrid learning for a link
simply visit 8newsnow.com